Leia make some sense of what's going on
with Bitcoin with the dollar with the
pound with nfts if you can just give us
kind of like a two minute high level
understand go for it later oh my God
there's so many questions I wrote a book
called undressing Bitcoin wait wait what
do you want to know specifically Bitcoin
of the pound like I want to know Bitcoin
and crypto and nfts minute dollar market
pound another minute you got this okay
so Bitcoin right now obviously is
massively down it's down from um it's
high of uh six nine thousand dollars
which was um back in November last year
so
um I'm still very bullish on bitcoin
Bitcoin is
um the only asset right now which looks
interesting to me there's a limited
Supply which is very important because
the reason that we're in this mess right
now is because they were printing
endless amounts of money so that's
really important
um with regards to
um where the market could be going
um I look at history so the last bull
market we saw um a correction of 80 so
we saw it from twenty thousand dollars
down to three thousand dollars that's 80
so so if I was to use that and predict
what the bottom of this Market could be
I would say if the highest 69k it would
come down to around 13 600 however
globally things are a massive mess right
now there's still a war going on um in
Europe with Russia and Ukraine
um we're seeing Anderson Earnest amounts
of money still being printed we now have
an energy crisis which means that like
things are very bad basically inflation
is going crazy so I would expect more
Black Swan events to potentially bring
Bitcoin even lower
um maybe around ten thousand dollars but
these are amazing buying opportunities
I'll be buying at this level
um do you want me to go into the pound
now yeah what's going on with the pound
okay so the pound like the Euro um is
absolutely crashing against the dollar
so usually the pound is that like I
think like one pound would buy you 1.30
now one pound will buy you almost a
dollar which is absolutely insane
um and again this is because they are
this is because they are um the uh the
Federal Reserve is increasing interest
rates so that strengthens the dollar
that's quantitative title and kind of
reversing what they previously did
um and that that's what's happening
everything is artificially induced the
energy crisis everything in the UK as a
result they're printing more money to
try to fix the issue which printing
money did
um which printing money calls so it's a
mess right now I really expect that the
Euro the pound and the dollar will all
hit one for one and then we all this is
my conspiracy theorist now we all get on
to one Global Currency which is the
dollar so now we're all on one uh Global
Currency and once uh we're all on the
same currency remember if you control
the mind you control the world we now
have one Central Bank which controls the
entire world
um and then they crash the dollar so
they [ __ ] us all basically and move us
onto something called a central bank
digital so I was just gonna go if
they're going to go to these CDC as well
cbdc so Central Bank digital currency so
this is basically um it's like a
cryptocurrency but it but it's not
because it's going to be entirely
centralized probably the FED if it
becomes the dollar and it'll be entirely
centralized which means that um they can
completely control the money they can
program it so if for whatever reason you
hold the wrong opinion you say the wrong
thing on social media you become an
Andrew Tate whatever it is
um it's much easier to shun you from
society because they can control your
money so they can program it sorry
Andrew you know you're too masculine for
us you're too toxic we'll just program
your money so you can't get that flight
back to Romania you can't get that
flight wherever it is
um that's basically what they're doing
so that's my overall take and that's why
I'm forever bullish on bitcoin because
the money is non-confiscatable so if you
don't get your vaccine it doesn't matter
we won't confiscate your money like
Justin Trudeau did uh the tyranny in
Canada uh the the Tyrant of Canada
um bitcoin's non-confiscatable limited
Supply decentralized so they can't uh
switch the network and tell people what
happened in Cyprus you know in Cyprus in
Cyprus in 2013 you had the cypriot
haircut which was basically
um because the they needed to bail out
the second largest bank in Cyprus in
order to do that
um they basically confiscated the money
of people who had over a hundred
thousand Euros in the bank I Think They
confiscated around 40 around 45 or maybe
47 and a half percent I can't fully
remember the number
um of their money so people woke up one
day to have their money gone because
those are the top made terrible calls
um the second largest bank needed to be
bailed out and so people had to pay for
it and that is disgusting They
confiscated their money money is the
fuel um sorry money is the energy which
fuels your life without freedom of money
you have freedom of nothing so that's
why I'm forever British on bitcoin um
and I definitely think it's going to go
back up um when the bull run hits and I
think that will be from 2024 onwards
after the halving event that's right so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sarscast click right here
foreign
[Music]